um
so uh
our our next talk
um is by devil ratshaw on puzzle
nature's commission
pray tell us about that
thanks chris uh
very nice to be here in person
my first confidence talk i presume
uh similar openings you have heard um
many times now in person so this is
based on joint work with anish agrawal
who is a graduate student at mit
mansardale who is my colleague mit and
dennis shen who is sitting here in this
purple mosque
and who is now uh who finished his phd
from mit and now he's a postdoc here
with the part of the 4c program
so here is the outline of the talk
uh please feel free to stop me this is
one of those nice
human talks so that
interaction would be extremely valued i
don't have too many things to go through
so of course that will help anyways and
i think i have to 11.
uh yes okay
uh
thank you
for the plus two yes so uh i will first
just quickly remind us what the matrix
completion question is of course it's
come up in uh different forms for
example in the last talk it came up
through in a form as a stochastic block
model
it will quickly remind the question um
give a few examples few a few of my uh
personally interesting example just
arguing that you know it's on one hand
there's a typical view of matrix
estimation or maybe it can be a more
interesting subroutine than just the way
we think about it
next i will spend some time discussing
the model um again so there's a signal
and there is an observation and it's an
observation part where causality comes
in
and i'll spend quite a bit of time
discussing that
briefly i'll do a literature review
there's a massive literature here so i
won't be able to do justice but i will
try to at least touch the highlights
terms of algorithms and the results
finally i'll describe an algorithm a
synthetic nearest neighbor primarily for
the causal model that i will introduce
here and again sort of
last few minutes i've spent some time
discussing um
why i think matrix completion and
some of the questions in causal
inference have a nice intimate
connections
so with that let's get started
so uh here is a one simple caricature
example so what i've done is that i've
drawn a five by five matrix so it's like
25 entries
and let's imagine that each entry
underlying ground truth is
corresponds to a coin so you have a
coin heads or tails you've got a bias
entry i j
ideal entry i j is p i j the bias of the
coin if you
toss it
and what you're observing is just few
coins tossed some tail some head and
some not tossed at all and from this i
want you to go and fill up
all the entries with the biases of the
coin
so
25
biases you want to fill up
from such sparse observations of course
if there's no structure there's nothing
you can do
so you hope and pray that there is some
structure one simple structure is well
this is all the same coins
in which case you will just do the
classical averaging
[Music]
matrix completion is a nice variation of
this question basically and for this
reason it's been a great question that
has driven lots of interesting
work over past couple of decades
just putting a little bit more formally
you've got some ground truth matrix a
let's say m times n matrix
you have
partial observations of it that is for
some entries
uh you observe something which is some
noisy version of it and again i'm not
specifying this yet
and for remaining you don't observe
anything
from this y you want to recover a hat so
that a hat is close to a in some some
norm okay and depending on norm you
might get different uh value out of this
again there's lots of details not yet
specified and i'll specify them in the
model because there are lots of options
but that is roughly at the highest level
what's happening
okay
again please feel free to stop me any
point of time
um now
uh
okay so i'll just go very quickly so
traditionally now maybe
at least one of the earliest matrix
completion question was in the paper by
goldberg attel where they proposed this
simple empirical algorithm collaborative
filtering in early 90s then
for example
nettie schreiber and yakula had a very
nice paper earlier in the beginning of
the century there's a whole list
where
a typical example is
what i would call a netflix challenge
setting where you have a matrix think of
these as
rating matrix users and movies and
you're trying to sort of estimate the
underlying matrix
with respect to minimizing let's say
normalized rabbinius now
here are just a few examples of
uh non-typical examples and again my
hope is that
with this you would
find matrix completion more than uh just
a netflix challenge so for example if
you
take the classical
multinomial logit model
which is a distribution over
permutations and you want to
estimate the underlying parameters from
pairwise comparison hidden underneath
work which is with uh seven when he was
at mit and sahan
at its core it's like you want a good
uh
good
handle of uh
the
the spectral norm error and that would
sort of help you sort of recover the
parameters of the model really well
there's lots of nice work subsequently
done some in the audience here itself
where folks are trying to get a better
approximation here which leads to better
approximation of the parameters
one of the things that
we tried to do
at mit with a bunch of students anisha
graval
denis shen and abdullah lamar
where we try to use some of these matrix
estimation based method as a way to
impute and forecast time series single
and multiple time series uh data
and actually
abdullah for example has gone ahead and
built a nice
nice database with prediction
property or prediction capabilities
within
it so if you like to play with actual
software is a
open source available at tspdb.mit.edu
please feel free to play with it give us
feedback that will be great
another way to look at matrix estimation
is
is an efficient sampling so again you
have lots of observations that you want
to know but if there's a structure maybe
only part of that you want to
extract and others you don't want to and
then fill them up and that's how we've
used it in
for reinforcement learning setting where
you want to learn a q function so q
function is state and actions and it's a
if you view that as a matrix or a
bivariate function then to approximate
that again you can use this as a
subroutine and finally close to this
talk
there's a very nice literature in
econometrics primarily on panel data
setting
and panel data is primarily or
longitudinal data is primarily the
question there is of some form of matrix
estimation and depending on what norm
you approximate
you would get different
causal estimates
okay and i'll sort of indulge into this
a little bit more as top progresses
okay so hopefully
uh at least
try to argue that this is an interesting
class of questions
beyond just a challenge
so let's sort of discuss the model
typically there's a
generic latent factor model which would
say that
the entry of the matrix that you care
about is some latent function
of
latent factors associated with row and
columns and these factors are lower
dimensional
while function is not something that you
don't know but hopefully it is well
structured for example it's something
like this which will mean that matrix is
low rank
okay
but more generally a function could be a
nice c infinity function or a lip sheet
function
and all of those would give rise to a
different model complexity
for example jamming has a really nice
work trying to
look at such a setup for the symmetric
or graphone setting
now
this is the ground truth
question is as far as the factors are
concerned or there is the use and visa
concern associated with rows and columns
um
one model is where you assume that these
are sampled from some underdying
distribution
okay and it's a this nice distribution
as in for example in the context of
graph1 or stochastic block model
and that leads to very nice structure it
imposes nice structure on the factors
collectively
or if you believe in the adversarial
setting or given instant setting then
one would assume conditions such as
incoherence condition where effectively
these are
well-structured factors so that if you
observe
any of the entries that give you enough
information about the underlying factors
and of course there's a question of
there are these two independent
quotes independent models do they have
any relationship with each other or not
and there is there is some uh really
interesting connection that these folks
have found but there is lot to be
discovered for example there's a notion
of pervasiveness has something to do
with this notion of incoherence and
pervasiveness is very stochastic
property versus incoherence is very
deterministic property and there's a
nice
work in that paper
okay so
for this talk
i'll assume that it's
low rank
and i will assume let's say a
deterministic property like this
okay
you could sort of slip many of those
things then
arguments would remain the same
so that's a ground truth signal that you
want to recover
what about observation
so if you observe an entry
it's a ground truth plus some noise i
will call it idiosyncratic noise as
independent
zero mean
but distribution may vary okay
for simplicity let's assume a
subgaussian distribution
or bounded distribution for the purpose
of the talk
that's if you observe the question is
that how do you observe how is the
missingness determined so
in the original model
one would assume that all entries are
missing at random or m c a are m car
what that means is that each entry i j
is observed with some probability p
okay so for every ij you flip a coin
if it comes up head with the bias p you
observe otherwise you don't and when you
observe it'll be like that
okay and then
if it's not missing at random so it's
not m car then it's mnr
okay so this is a this is a
large model okay
so we need to sort of we need some model
within this to make sense otherwise it's
kind of
terrible so i'll sort of
i'll open the brackets here
just to sort of point out a few
nice references that introduce this
or discuss this
in detail are by chevrolet and then
more recently by little and rubin
okay
now
in the m novel so there's an m car where
entries are observed uniformly at random
if not in that massive space there's one
thing which i would call limited mnr
okay which has been
now at least lately studied well
here what one would uh assume is that
each entry
is observed
so for each entry you have a
biased coin but the bias of the coin for
each entry is different
in particular let's say p i j is the
probability with which
entry i j is observed and you would
require some kind of a minimum
positivity condition that is minimum
over i j is greater than some p star
okay and then there is a structure in
this
so
given this kind of a limited model where
again
entries are observed independently but
the
the intensity with which they're
observed is different for every i j
and then sort of the intensity with
which they're observed has some
structure
and there's a minimal or positivity
condition
so there's a
bunch of nice works recently uh for
example this just came out like a month
ago
by bhattachar and chatterjee the
question is what can one do this now
this is called limited mnr because
effectively there is a simple reduction
one could think of at least in principle
to the m car setting
so
let's consider two
m car problems okay so again m car is
just missing completely random
problem one
consider a matrix where whatever was
observed was observed whatever is not
observed replaced by zero
okay
and
on that matrix effectively now you got
everything observed nothing is missing
you run your algorithm your favorite m
car algorithm and obtain x hat
now let's take another m car problem
take the same data
but wherever you observe y i j you
replace by one that's your effectively
and wherever you don't observe you
replace by zero so it's your mask
okay again everything is observed
like in stochastic block model
okay and then again you run your
favorite m car algorithm on this you
obtain m hat and then just do this
uh
these re-weighting and this is your
estimate
and hopefully if your
m car algorithms were good
and because you have this nice
positivity condition hope is that this
might work out
and
this collection of work
now of course
is a lot more detailed than just what i
said
and that needs to be worked out and lots
of those nice things are worked out in
this works
okay
so in particular problem two is what
cornelius
and again sort of if you want some kind
of a nice estimation here because you're
you're dividing
entry-wise how that goes
some care
for example this one um talks about um
two methods and establishes that
consistency
okay so
so m car limited mnr now i'll
what i'll call is a causal model and
i'll argue that why this is an
interesting model so i'll spend some
time just describing what this is
again um
as before aij is a low rank
okay
if i observe entry it's a i j plus some
epsilon i j
question is that when do i observe it
let's call that matrix d d i j is one if
i observe it zero otherwise
this is a random variable the entries
may be dependent
okay
um
and let's look at this effectively the
this dag
so entries of d
may depend arbitrarily on the latent
factors of all rows and columns
of course if i observe an entry
it's a function of this plus a noise
now there could be an additional edge
here
where
entries that are observed actually are
based on the noise itself
for example let's suppose that um
uh here's what i'll do
as an oracle
in that original 25 coin example i gave
you
what i'll do is i'll flip all coins
first
okay some of them are zeros and some of
them are ones then i will go and reveal
only those coins which are zeros so from
your observation perspective you'll see
everything zero right
now that means that in that case
i am
revealing entries after looking at the
epsilon there is a random outcome and
that's not allowed because that's
terrible i mean then nobody can help you
so i will just simply prevent that part
but i will allow you to have dependence
arbitrarily on this
your probability of observing any ij
could be zero
for that matter
and
this dag would imply that conditionally
what entries i've observed and
the observed random variable are
independent
given
the uvs but otherwise they are dependent
if i don't condition them
now uh why is this a reasonable model
so let's take sort of just one example
like this they
think of again setting of yelp
where you go to restaurants
uh
which you are likely to like
of your which you're uh
hopefully you don't go to a restaurant
which you're not likely to like
but then sort of you go there and then
you try it and then maybe you reveal
something or not right
similar in the context of
policy evaluation things like let's say
what policy went into effect in united
states for
kovaid versus what mosque policies
going in effect in united states in
different regions for kovade all of that
depends on the characteristics of the
the region
of course there is an uh
noise that is not determining
uh whether what policy decisions are
happening
so this includes the case where the
the yelp user
uh reveals a review of
a restaurant if it's the kind of
restaurant they normally like
but not the case where they reveal it or
not depending partly on whether they did
actually like it
yeah so i think so
uh exactly so the question is where in
the model the epsilon is absolutely
any questions about the model
this is the only difference is how i'm
revealing the entries
and again this is a confounding as i
mentioned and
of course in this case would allow you
to have a
lack of positivity
that is some entries would never
couldn't would never be observed for
that matter
so um
i'm going to skip this example because
we know what confounding is and i've
given you a simple example
um
all right so let's sort of look at
what's known in the literature and again
there are a few parts here one is
different types of algorithms and then
what sorts of results we know for
different types of models
so there are a few algorithms one i
would call it a spectral algorithm
optimization based algorithm or this
uh nonparametric or nearest neighbor or
collaborative filtering style algorithms
um
and i would say the sort of
sum of square based method would
hopefully fit into one of these two
categories
uh one simplest spectral algorithm is uh
singular value thresholding there's you
take the matrix replace missing values
by zero or values like row averages or
column averages or something more clever
like that and then do's uh singular
value decomposition and threshold data
truncated
uh optimization based method would try
to avoid looking at the missing values
and simply try to fit factors
uh based on observed entries
and then nearest neighbors are simply
trying to
use the observed entries for rows or
columns and somehow
compute the features from there and the
nearest neighbor out of that
now there is a panel data method that's
called synthetic control and i'll
briefly describe what that is
that evolved independently from many of
this literature and as you can see from
the date
and it has very similar flavor to
nearest neighbors but it's the nearest
neighbors with uh kind of ordinary least
squares involved and i'll describe what
that is but for a very specific
observation pattern
this is kind of a scorecard if you
like those things for m car setting
where
all of these are efficient algorithms
that is polynomial time algorithms and
statistical guarantees now it is
possible that i might have missed some
of the
exponents or logs incorrectly in some of
the places
because this was uh
uh i had surveyed it two years ago so
it's possible that something is wrong
but bottom line is that
if you have um missing at random if
you're rank r matrix then n times r
times some logs is what you want as a
number of observations to get consistent
estimation
many of those works are primarily for
frobenius norms but there is a lot more
progress now towards different norms and
again i'm i'm missing lots of entries
for example one nice recent paper by
chanatel tries to obtain entry wise
gaussian approximation
um
and then that enables entry entrywise
sort of confidence in interval
construction
in the context of uh
mnr setting
if you look at a panel data setting and
i'll describe what that is which
effectively
if you look at the matrix there's a some
number of columns are fully observed and
then some number of rows are fully
observed
it's kind of a half t observation
pattern
for that there are synthetic control
like methods
uh do work well you can think of them as
some form of limited mnr setting
um
for the model that i described of
limited mnr
as a
few of the nice recent works there that
try to establish consistency
and
that's basically what we know for that
setup
now what i'll do is just to
sometimes pictures are
a lot more effective than all the
theorem statements so here is a simple
experiment that i'm going to show you
okay so what this is is
a simple low rank matrix
for that a low rank matrix no noise okay
what i'm going to do is uh okay so the
factors are generated by uh sampling
uh
uh
gaussian entries for the vectors and
then normalizing them
and then so now i generated matrix look
at all entries of the matrix
plot the histogram of it
and that's how it looks like
it's a shaded light blue
then
draw entries uniformly at random from it
for example like that so dots
corresponds to observed entries white
corresponding not observed entries
and then plot that histogram now of
course the number
absolute number would be smaller because
i'm sub sampling but as you can see the
shape is similar
if i normalize and pull this up
there is an overlap on each other
so that's just uh
entries of entire matrix and how that
histogram looks like
now using these blue entries
let's apply
the
the us the universal singular value
thresholding algorithm and see the
histogram of
the filled matrix
and the histogram field matrix is quite
skewed
and
if you see the frequency is much higher
than
what you would have hoped in the
original matrix
okay so instead of actually it is
introducing quite a bit of
bias even in the
missing at random setting again this is
really nice setup
because my factors are really nice no
noise okay
instead we applied the and there's a
nice implementation of soft compute
this
optimization based algorithm
and as you can see it hides the
true histogram behind it
this really works really well
and the algorithm that i'll show you uh
which is primarily for causal model but
of course if it's not causal it's still
part of causal
um it also sort of works well and it
hides well
so this is uh missing at random
now i'll keep the matrix same but change
the observation pattern
so in particular this is limited mnr
settings so remember each entry is still
observed or not observed independently
but with likelihoods are different
and there's a positivity constraint
in which case it looks something like
this and as you can see there is a sort
of pattern skewed by design
and it's a
it's a low rank
pattern matrix
uh on a in mean okay and so again
not normalized but sort of it has these
two bumps now
so clearly sort of it's it is not am car
now you apply
usvt
at least visually it looks better than
before
but
look at the sort of the
uh the magnitude here it's much bigger
than before so actually it's a lot more
skewed
okay so it's not the improvement it's
gotten worse
uh
there's a version of algorithm that i
briefly described us a few slides ago
which is
applying let's say usb style algorithm
twice
that would do terribly uh it would sort
of effectively be out of the
chart so i'm not showing that
we applied the optimization based method
and again nice thing about optimization
based method is it doesn't take into
account what's not observed it only
looks at things that are observed and
again there's a bias there
and this algorithm continues to work but
again bias is small here
then the last one
which is really
uh
this causal setting where some of the
entries will have
um
uh will not be observed some of the
entries will be observed and the
decision is made based on looking at the
latent factors of users and or let's say
rows and columns
it is quite biased
the same trend continues for uswt
now
uh the optimization based on soft
compute
uh does very poorly and here i'm just
truncating it because i know
what's the range in which it is
but this algorithm continues working
so there is something about uh how we
observe and how sort of
uh how we sort of incorporate
observations which would lead to sort of
different types of outcomes
so now in the
maybe remaining 10 minutes or so i'll
just describe what the algorithm is
where the
what guarantees we can provide and maybe
some discussion
any questions
so intuitively you can do better in the
causal case because
you can learn something from an
unobserved
entry about isolated
that i'm plotting there which i have not
described yet
it would not try to learn anything
actually
about unobserved things it's only trying
to sort of focus on the observed things
only
and
uh
basic point is that if you just focus on
observed things
in a way that sort of
you can convince yourself under this
kind of model
that the observations that you're
looking at are not biased
then you can actually recover the signal
so in a sense sort of
uh
look at look at less than more
fewer of the observations in a nice
structured manner and they'll sort of
take care of it and again sort of the
idea is very simple so
it's nothing complicated um
i do believe though there are better
uh algorithms for this model than sort
of what i would put out there
um
and again sort of hopefully that will
sort of lead to better sample complexity
the question
okay so now the algorithm
so first let's just quickly remind
ourselves what is the nearest neighbor
then i'll remind you what is the
synthetic control and then when you put
those two things together we'll get
synthetic nearest neighbor
okay
so
i'll use picture just to describe but
again sort of
details of the algorithms will be
skipped for obvious reasons
so
think of again rows and columns and
let's say you want to
figure out what this entry is
the typical nearest neighbor cell
algorithm would say that here is row i
let me find another row that looks like
this
one way to find that is look at all the
columns in which the share entries for
example these ones
and if they look
close enough which is my nearest
neighbor on the observed entries then i
will look at the entry that
that row has for this column and maybe
i'll just
use that sort of and extrapolate it
and of course in reality you would try
to compute
multiple nearest neighbors take the
average maybe use some form of weighting
do variation of it through kernel and
whatnot
so there was that's a nearest
neighbor-like algorithm
a synthetic control algorithm
again originally proposed by the body
adele it's a nice survey he has recent
recently
which would
which tries to
estimate counterfactual in the absence
of intervention and
it's a very interesting panel data
setting so think of
think of the following situation let's
say
um
one scenario in which
here is a time when you implement a
policy
in uh
in a country in a region for example
let's suppose that we decided to
try out what happens to massachusetts
crime rate if we imposed some form of
gun control
well let's say
before that all the states had no such
law
and
this was the measurement of some kind of
a crime rate
measured weekly or measured monthly or
whatever
now on this day massachusetts implements
uh
the the policy
so whatever observation we're going to
get on massachusetts are going to be
under a different policy than what we uh
what we would like to know and what we
would really like to know is what would
have happened to massachusetts if it had
not implemented the crime rate sorry the
gun control
if it had not implemented can control
and if we would see what the outcomes
would be then we can compare them with
the observed outcomes where observed
outcomes are under intervention and now
we have effectively this comparison
setting and now we can decide whether
can control really help message you sets
or not
so with that setting
effectively what one is trying to do is
for a given
row
i want to observe
outcomes in some number of columns
okay which are completely missed
but assume that all the other states
before and after continue to remain in
the same situation there is no policy
implemented
so i'm going to observe all of the
entries here all of the entries here and
here and then i want to fill this up
okay so that's the
typical
synthetic control panel data differences
in difference before that another style
of methods
setting
and
the algorithm there roughly goes like
this that
you would think of these as
your training example so these are your
my features
and this is my label
and then from there i'm going to do
effectively ordinary least squares but
with some structure on it
some regularization
and then once i learn this model
again i know all of these things well
because i just observed them
and now i will sort of
utilize the model that i learned between
this row and other rows and extrapolate
it
okay it's very simple
and
it's called synthetic control and
at least in original work this was um
this was required to be
non-negative weights
because the idea was that
massachusetts is 80 like california and
maybe
twenty percent like texas
uh and so so you wanna sort of keep the
non-negative weights that add up to one
um
one of the things that so early on that
sort of uh
with dennis and
changi we found that
instead of doing that if we simply
utilized
um
[Music]
matrix estimation based denoising
actually it worked
much better
in many of the empirical settings and
you could sort of say something more
formally about that
and so primarily it becomes pcr
so now i'm going to put those two
algorithms together
for uh problems that we were discussing
okay so just nearest neighbor with the
synthetic control
again i'm going to show you with the
pictures and i'm going to skip lots of
details
imagine that this is the entry i want to
fill
and this is the type of observations you
have
so there's a row i column j that's what
is missing
there's some entries you observed in row
i
some entries you observed in column j
now i'm sorted it so that it looks nice
and clean
and
uh
now let me call
entries in which
row i has i have observed something
let's call these columns and c of i
for column j the entries that i observe
corresponding to those rows let's call
this nr
okay
that forms this
square for me
now inside that let me identify a square
s
but i observed everything
and this is what uh i was saying that
i'm going to now ignore everything else
but just use this square
and now i'm going to sort of treat this
as
effectively a
synthetic control like
with variation on that with nearest
neighbors
in particular what i will do
is that
let me think of
these entries
as my
labels
these are my features
i'm going to learn a linear model
between them
just as before that i will
this entire matrix i will denoise using
singular value thresholding
just this part
and then i will try to learn linear
model that's effectively i'm applying
principal component regression
uh use that
with these as my let's say
the test features now and then sort of
estimate
yeah
that's fully observed or not here
s is fully observed okay so where do you
use singular value thresholding what are
you still only on this one
it's not fully up there
there will be noise here right
so while this is a matrix which is fully
observed but it's a noisy entry a noisy
observation that i've got lots of
websites
so remove the noise
now of course this is only one uh entry
algorithm typically in nearest neighbor
you want many things so what do you do
if actually bootstrap like things on top
of this
so you will sort of have multiple
squares out of these and then sort of
create multiple estimators and then
average
and once you'll do that then sort of you
will get uh
nice
confidence intervals for each entry
so in
um
okay good so um
it is hard and
all the empirical results i showed you
we simply sort of ran a simple greedy
algorithm to do that
but it's um it's a good point and that's
why sort of
um
uh results that i'm proving here really
are assuming some kind of you know
witness is existing
and so they're not sort of the strongest
form because you're not sort of fully
utilizing all the information you can
but the chances are better of this kind
of rectangle existing in the causal
model than in
far right i mean
so uh
correlations between
the that at least intuitively definitely
makes sense
um
so here what i'm going to do is i'm
going to sort of state a theorem with a
certain sort of assumption so this is
just usual
the key thing is this observation
pattern and in particular i'm saying
that let's say that there exists
an s
which is say k by k raised to three by
two
okay or other way down i mean because
the dimensions don't matter
if you have that for a given entry i j
because for every entry i j this is
different but a given entry i j if you
have this
then
with high probability you would be able
to get a bound like this
and again so the high probabilities with
respect to k
not with the latent dimension now one
might ask the question that
does this kind of a square have a chance
to exist right
so we say okay i don't know sort of
generic
mnr model
but instead what i'll do at least go
back and see what happens in am car
setting
so for example if you have a
density like this
and by n matrix a density like this
then
it will effectively result into an error
bound like this
for every entry
again i don't think this is a this is
just a very simple calculation so
definitely this can be tightened
um
because you can sort of do
a multiple estimation out of it and then
sort of
get
averaging
this average estimation will satisfy a
nice
nice central limit theorem also as k
increases
and this sigma twiddle k i'm not writing
down the formula but effectively it's
coming in because
different entries might have different
uh
variants and then they are combined with
the model that you're learning
so it'll be
that um
standard deviation
okay
all right and i've got one more minute
left right
okay uh i'll skip all of these things
dennis took on to himself and say you
know what i'm going to go through
the whole zoo of
matrix estimation algorithm that are out
there
so he actually
looked at every code that he could find
online um and then sort of
these details are in the paper
i'll leave you with that
and just sort of do one sort of quick
discussion in our land
so
uh
there are many ways to think of causal
inference uh one simplest way to think
of causal inferences
at least the challenge of it is that
you've got some outcome that you're
interested in
you've got some intervention that you
care about and you've got some
confounders sometimes latent sometimes
observed okay and ignoring the noise
effectively the outcome is some function
of
intervention
and the confounder or latent factor
latent confounders
and when it's observed setting the
interventions are also dependent on your
confounders if it's experimental then
there is no such dependence and that's
why i'm putting dash dash
so
for example
if i want to find out
what would be the effect of an
intervention a over entire population
i say well
let's sample individuals from entire
population which is effectively sampling
u
and all of them get a
and i observe this and this will help me
understand the population level
uh
potential outcome
but
what if i say that in this particular
there is a person it's a person guy
i don't know corresponding the he's uh
confirmed
or
the
latent confounders associated with him
or characteristics associated with him
and for him itself i want to know what
happens to him under a what happens to
him under b what happens to him under c
that would require me to know this
function f and u associated with him
right
those are the two things if i know f and
if i know you i'm done
um
now
of course you don't observe all the
entries so you have to somehow
extrapolate it
now this matrix completion-like setting
says that you know this function that
you have effectively factorizes nicely
which means that even if you observe few
places you can extrapolate it to the all
possible
rows and columns are all possible
interventions and the individuals
and
you don't need to know the the latent
confounder associated with individual
because you are somehow learning
relationship between them
through other rows that matter for the
purpose of your predictions
so
in a sense at least
when you have
lots of observations available for each
individual
these are high dimensional observations
available for individuals then maybe
this might be a way to at least
solve some of the causal problems
and definitely as you see this this
already sort of seems like
uh
solving uh high dimensional mixture
problems for that matter
anyways i'll leave you with this last
remark
and questions
so one or two quick questions before our
break i mean we have a we have a three
hour
thanks so i i thought it was interesting
the way you diagnose the performance of
different methods by looking at the
histograms of the recovered values yes
and when i see this the first thing i'm
tempted to do is to just use it and uh
you know just to be sure at least that
i'm doing good on this thing that you're
actually measuring but are there any
methods that actually try to calibrate
uh
matrix recovery because you could you
could you know you could estimate the
distributions of your sensoring and you
could estimate the distributions that
you could deconvolve the distribution of
the observations and then just use this
like some penalty that just forces your
method to actually stick to that and do
so i'm guessing you're not using this at
all but do you know if there's any
methods that try to actually stick to
that it's a great question i don't know
thanks
questions
yeah actually related to the previous
question so about this histogram is that
because like your
method works better in terms of infinity
norm so you have an entry wise control
so it kind of looks much better than say
for example universal single variable
shorting
so there is more on the formation one i
think there is more than that so for
example this soft impute cell method
um
uh i think it's because of observational
uh pattern
so soft impute-like method that we had
used it to
uh
uh learn the q function where
in that setup the ways of of
observations are where obtained were
designed because we were interested in
sort of efficient sampling
and while there's no
theorem for that setting to the best of
my understanding
it provided really good entrywise
guarantee
so i would believe that i don't know if
anybody has done empirical analysis but
soft compute like method in the m car
setting would provide really good
entrywise uh or length and genome
guarantee
uh but i think in this case it sort of
ends up doing poorly
actually i have another question uh it's
okay so about the theorem that you're
showing so about this click yeah you're
finding this by click yeah maybe i
missed that so so i thought that in this
uh if you do not observe a lot of
entries then the size of the largest by
clicking
is probably very small like even
constant log gamma too
uh that's okay so that's why
i wanted to sort of at least show that
simple calculation that is
at least there is some regime where the
fraction of observed entries are
is
is going to zero
still the sort of num uh the number of
bike leaks that you would observe with
each of the size would be sort of large
enough
uh so that was that sort of thing
there's a uh
the observed uh each entry is observed
with a n to the power minus delta
and then
you would be able to
with whatever observe whatever sort of
bi-click size you observed apply method
applied it will give you uh entry-wise
error to be delta to power 1 over 12.
again i think uh
it's um
uh
it i don't think it's a fully tight
analysis maybe 1 over 12 could be
improved to 1 over 3.
i don't know if you can do better than
that
one more question
okay
in the end does it give you a lowering
matrix uh as a estimate or
is the is it like a nuclear minimizing
setting good so we did not impose the
low rank constraint on it it's more
flexible because it's sort of what entry
uh what entry estimation right it seems
like that might be why you're
one of the reasons why you're gaining is
you are allowing it to be more flexible
like this of course other methods are
restricted to be lowering in this
comparison right
they're exactly low rank
that's an interesting
point i don't
immediately agreed to that for the
simple reason that underlying true
matrix itself is also low rank that
you're trying to approximate right right
so
uh but maybe sort of your point is of
because algorithm has flexibility
somehow that flexibility allows you to
discover the right thing rather than
maybe yeah it's a great point yeah
all right let's thank you again